one of the things i try to avoid on this
show is to be hyperbolic and when people
are going crazy about something and it's
really no big deal i try to just say
this is really not that big of a deal
let's talk about it but let's talk about
it in sort of sober and reasonable terms
but
that is very much not the case when it
comes to the peril that
is on the horizon
if republicans were to win the 2022
midterm elections in what are just a few
months now quite frankly and when i say
democracy is in jeopardy if republicans
take the house in 2022 i say it with the
caveat that this is not a hyperbolic
claim
and increasingly i mean the bad thing is
that democracy is in peril if
republicans win the good thing is
increasingly people are understanding
this peril and this risk
republicans and democrats
who are so similar on so many issues
we've talked about it before here's a
whole bunch of issues on which there's
really no
significant difference between
republicans and democrats how could it
be
that if republicans take one chamber of
congress
it would have such a major impact and
the answer is that
it is because of the destructive
potential that the series of events that
could be unleashed by republicans taking
control of the house
is so significant that it could be the
catalyst for a disaster for democracy
and let's just think it through
first we know that republicans see their
2020 failure
as a failure to steal the election what
i mean by that is when you hear
republicans talk about 2020 most of them
i mean okay mitt romney's the exception
liz cheney's the exception but for the
most part when you hear trump people
associated with the trump white house
the more weaponized republicans in the
house and senate when they talk about
what happened in 2020
their view is
we
we just didn't do enough
to take the election from the guy who
won it they don't think you know next
time we should really win by appealing
to more voters and getting more people
to vote for us that would be the normal
reaction that would be the pro-democracy
reaction not enough we didn't convince
enough people let's be better at
convincing people to vote for us no they
think we can win next time by better
working to take the election even when
we don't win it using different
techniques or being better with the
techniques that we used in 2022 but we
just didn't do enough of so with a
midterm 2022 win
they would be far better to carry out
that um
upending of democracy in 2024 that's a
very dangerous thing secondly marjorie
taylor green
matt gates
and others in that uh cohort have said
if we win in 2022
we're going to investigate joe biden
we're going to investigate hunter biden
who has nothing to do with the
administration we will end the january
6th committee if it's still going on we
will impeach joe biden and on and on and
on they've said that that's what they're
going to do
disaster and thirdly they've said if
they win
they will quickly work
to help the trump rioters avoid
consequences to any extent that they can
effectively rewarding the rioters for
what they did on january 6th of 2021
now
in response to this nancy pelosi who i
am not a fan of
nancy pelosi recently said quote it is
absolutely essential for our democracy
that we win i fear for our democracy if
the republicans were ever to get the
gavel we can't let that happen and some
people are like oh she's being
hyperbolic but remember that canadian
political scientist thomas homer dixon
who we interviewed recently he also
wrote and explained to us during the
interview that the united states could
be under a right-wing dictatorship by
2030 and when i asked him well what talk
to us about the sequence what are the
initial steps and the precursor steps to
a right-wing dictatorship in 2030
include
trump winning in 2024
and a precursor to that would of course
be republicans taking the house in 2022
so the stakes are absolutely huge and if
we just say what's most likely i'm not
saying throw in the towel i'm not saying
don't try if anything what i'm saying is
we've got to try
the more likely outcome even though
nancy pelosi won't admit it is that
republicans take the house in 2022. if
nothing significant changes republicans
only have to flip five seats remember to
take control of the house in november
that's the most likely outcome that they
are able to flip at least five seats it
is a very small margin of error for
democrats now the other aspect to all of
this is of course
is the department of justice going to
act at all to show that what took place
in 2020 simply cannot happen again and
truly hold people accountable
i uh
you know i i have no emotional
investment in merrick garland one way or
the other but it's increasingly looking
like merrick garland is sort of
spineless and we're going to talk later
trump is again asking putin to help him
find dirt on people this time hunter
biden will talk about that a little bit
later in the show but it doesn't seem
merrick garland wants to do anything
we've got these manhattan investigators
who resigned including mark pomerance
saying
we had good evidence that trump
committed crimes
if we tried some of these cases
we would likely win but it doesn't seem
any charges are coming there and
multiple prosecutors have resigned as a
result a federal judge recently said and
we talked about it earlier this week
it's pretty apparent that donald trump
committed felonies and yet what
nothing
the department of justice seems to be
completely feckless and
you have to understand that this is
bigger than just merit garland in
general number one the checks and
balances that we have are checks and
balances
but they never accounted for someone
like trump they just didn't and we
talked about this during the trump era
and the federal bureaucracy in general
has never really held presidents
accountable in any serious way so about
ten different things have to happen
including democrats earning more votes
the doj taking this seriously and
unfortunately uh
it sort of seems like many democrats are
more willing to allow the possibility of
democracy dying than to take the gloves
off and saying hey you know what we do
have to do some unprecedented things but
that's because we've already had
unprecedented circumstances the trump
presidency was already unprecedented and
when that's the case
you might have to take unprecedented
action very scary times ahead
and it is not hyperbolic to say
that democracy is in peril
as yet another example of this let's
talk about
yet another request from donald trump to
vladimir putin
so
trump is again asking putin to help him
find dirt
you might remember that donald trump
previously said russia if you're
listening
you will be rewarded for hacking
hillary's emails in the dnc and then
within hours that's exactly what russia
did
we are in the middle right now globally
of a russian invasion of ukraine an
invasion of aggression and illegal
invasion an invasion that doesn't
respect the sovereignty of the ukrainian
people or of the ukrainian borders
that's what's going on
and not only has donald trump praised
putin as a genius and savvy and smart
early in the invasion not only has trump
used very soft language about putin like
saying recently that he's driven to put
it together in reference to the invasion
of ukraine trump
is now asking putin
can you give us some dirt
on hunter biden dozens of articles about
this including this article from
politico trump calls on putin to release
dirt on hunter biden it's the latest
example of the former president
soliciting foreign governments to
intervene to damage his domestic
political rivals remember he also
withheld aid from ukraine
wanting ukraine to announce an
investigation into the biden family for
the pr benefit he ultimately was sort of
shamed into giving ukraine the military
aid once that information leaked or or
broke so trump appears on real america's
voice we'll look at other pieces of this
interview later in the show
and trump says
you know we're not going to get the
truth about hunter from ukraine
but maybe putin can give it to us listen
to this this is as crazy as it has been
made out to be i think while i'm on your
show as long as putin now is not exactly
a fan of our country
let him explain where did because chris
wallace wouldn't let me ask the question
what
why did the mayor of moscow's wife
give the bidens both of them three and a
half million dollars that's a lot of
money
she gave him three and a half million
dollars
so now i would think
putin would know the answer to that i
think he should release it i think we
should know that answer wow now you
won't get the answer from ukraine but
why are they giving somebody
who knows nothing about energy
187 thousand dollars a month
plus a three million dollar upfront
payment
and i won't even talk about china
because they haven't gone into yeah
taiwan yet right that'll be next
i love the hosts nodding along like they
have any idea what trump is talking
about but why did the mayor of moscow's
wife
give the biden family three and a half
million dollars
nobody wants to ask the question and
chris wallace
who's a total lightweight unlike his
father who interviewed me for 60 minutes
was actually a good piece
mike wallace was great he wants to be
mike wallace but he doesn't have the
talent
but why is it that
the mayor of moscow's wife gave the
biden family three and a half million
dollars now of course he he mean for p i
for people who are confused why is trump
talking about a female horse he's saying
the mayor not the mayor okay just just
that could be just a new york accent
thing i know people in the audience will
say horses what is he talking about i
know that we've lost our
our capacity for shock
but the president of the united states
uh
is trying to fight
russia because russia is invading
ukraine
uh fight through sanctions and fight
through training i'm talking about joe
biden
while a former president of the united
states in the middle of that fight
is asking a nato adversary that is
illegally invading another country
to help him politically
that's what donald trump is doing and of
course this isn't the first time that
trump has done it this is that famous
time the russia if you're listening
debacle russia if you're listening
i hope you're able to find the 30 000
emails
that are missing
i think you will probably be rewarded
mightily by our press and hours later
that is exactly what russia is believed
to have done the difference is that this
time there may be less of a payoff to
russia to releasing so-called dirt if it
exists on hunter biden whereas there was
a significant payoff back then because
we know of russia's preference for trump
over hillary clinton so he's doing it
again
later in the show we'll look at some
other moments from this disturbing
interview
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is primarily
funded by our audience people who listen
to the podcast watch clips on youtube
listen to the show on the radio maybe on
your local radio station you can support
our work by signing up at
joinpackman.com and we do an extra show
every single day for our members you can
also now gift memberships to others when
you sign up just check the box this is a
gift membership if you want to give the
gift to someone specific you can if you
leave it blank
we'll give it to someone we've got a
waiting list right now of 220 people who
have requested
memberships and can't afford them so
that is something that is available as
well joinpakman.com
we must follow up i am driven i am
determined to follow up about a story
that is increasingly smelling like
watergate yesterday i told you about
these roughly seven hours of missing
call logs that the trump white house has
turned over to the january sixth
committee investigating the trump riot
so to reset the entire thing and get
everybody on the same page
for a period of time now the january 6th
committee has been wanting the logs of
who did donald trump speak to on january
6th and it turns out that what was
provided to the investigative committee
is missing seven hours and as i told you
yesterday this was during some very key
hours between 11 17 a.m and 6 54 p.m
this is the most important time of the
riots it's from just before
they started heading towards the capital
through the period of time during which
we now know trump was being urged even
by people in his family like ivanka to
call in the national guard tell people
to go home to the point at which donald
trump gave that very mealy-mouthed and
soft and squishy appeal to his followers
to go home even though they were
completely right to be there because the
election after all was stolen as trump
said through to when people actually
started leaving the capital this is the
key time
we're going to follow up in a moment on
donald trump's claim that he doesn't
know what a burner phone is because one
of the aspects of this is
not only are seven hours missing
even if trump didn't make any phone
calls on white house phones during that
time
he clearly was talking to people and he
may have been using burner phones we're
going to follow up about that in the
next segment but the first part of this
is that talking points memo has done
something fascinating which is they have
assembled media reports
where others acknowledge speaking to
trump during that time and they are now
able to say with a high degree of
certainty
here are at least some of the calls
missing from the call logs now whether
they're missing because
they're just
missing and haven't been turned over or
whether they're missing because burner
phones or other people's phones were
used we don't yet know but this is very
very interesting talking points memo
trump was 100 percent making phone calls
during the january 6th attack here's the
list and what they've done is they've
assembled media reports and they've said
here here are calls that have been
acknowledged
which aren't recorded anywhere so for
example mike pence the official records
turned over to the committee don't
include trump's final call with mike
pence on january 6 during which the
president made a last attempt to
pressure pence to illegally hijack the
election certification process
then pence advisor general keith kellogg
testified under oath about the
conversation the washington post
reported on the call bob woodward and
robert costa surfaced the call in their
book peril so that is a specific call
with three sources
that is not on the logs so that's that's
a call there's no record of it in what
the trump administration has turned over
to investigators okay next call house
minority leader kevin mccarthy we know
about this call trump had an explosive
call with the house minority leader
kevin mccarthy right in the middle of
the attack
representative jamie herrera butler
confirmed the call said mccarthy briefed
her on the call that's the conversation
where trump responding to the gop leader
sounding the alarm of violence remarked
well kevin i guess the people are more
upset about the election than you are
according to butler that's a specific
call that we have independently sourced
it's not on the records turned over by
trump so that's another call that took
place during those seven hours
senators mike lee and tommy tuberville
senator mike lee told the salt lake
tribune he got a call from trump moments
after the capitol police stopped the
senate proceedings i believe that was
around 1 30 p.m eastern i'm going it was
a crazy day i'm going from memory but
it's certainly within that seven hour
window of missing calls the caller id
indicated the call was coming from the
white house according to lee but he
didn't know it was trump until he picked
up
according to lee trump misdialed and was
trying to call senator tommy tuberville
so lee handed his phone to the alabama
senator in the wake of the attack
tuberville revealed he told trump in the
call that pence was being evacuated
third call missing from the logs trump
was on the phone
this call
from the white house so this was not
with a burner phone the caller id was
the white house
jim jordan now this one we've spoken
about so many times and jim jordan has
been extremely dishonest and deceptive
about how many times did you speak to
trump on that day
the official call logs include one call
between trump and jordan at 9 24 am
we now know with the benefit of
hindsight
jordan has admitted to more than one
call
that day and at least one was during the
attack so at minimum we know that
there's one acknowledged jim jordan call
not reflected in the records turned over
by trump and then lastly congressman
matt gates
politico reported that gates was on one
of jordan's calls to trump during which
they urged trump to call off the
supporters storming the building
so uh that is uh gates himself has
refused to say if he was part of the
call but politico he hasn't denied it
and politico has reported it so again
that if that's with jim jordan and
during the attacks it's during that
seven hour window
these are all easily verified by public
statements and of course i don't know if
and how republicans will even try to
spin this they will probably say
it's a fishing expedition this is a bad
faith committee it's a committee that
needs to be ended it's politically
oriented because they don't have any
republicans other than two anti-trump
republicans that's because they refuse
to be on it everybody else refused to be
on it um so we do have the ability to
figure out at least some of these calls
records can be cross-checked and then
from the standpoint of the investigative
committee
if they successfully subpoena the phone
records of the people on the other ends
of these phone calls
then they would be able to say well
here's a call in jim jordan's phone
log
and it's not reflected in what the white
house gave us
that's a call that they have hidden from
us so
clearly that's something that they can
do
and this is stinking more and more
uh like
like watergate and we're going to talk
about that a little later let's now dig
in a little bit to the whole burner
phone thing
so
the next piece of the seven hours of
missing call logs story
is the obviously unbelievable claim from
donald trump that he doesn't even know
what burner phones are
so as a reminder yesterday we reported
to you
white house records turned over to the
january 6 committee are missing about
seven and a half hours of logs this is a
key seven and a half hours while the
insurrection was going on and one of the
sort of notable things
that came out of this was that donald
trump denied
having any idea what a burner phone is
in a statement monday night trump said i
have no idea what a burner phone is to
the best of my knowledge i have never
even heard the term
this stunk to high heaven and when i
told you this yesterday the story we
didn't know about john bolton's recent
comments
it was not plausible that trump didn't
know the term burner phone
and it was certainly not plausible that
trump doesn't know
about disposable phones
if you wanted to be as charitable as
possible and give trump the benefit of
the doubt which i don't know why we
would do at this point but let's say we
did you might be able to argue trump
knows of them as disposable phones
and he doesn't know or remember the term
burner phone but that it wasn't even
believable it really wasn't we now have
new reporting from donald trump's former
national security adviser who says he
specifically remembers trump using the
term burner phones and of course this is
completely believable and completely
obvious and it's what we suspected right
away
cbs news reporting john bolton the
former national security adviser to
trump told cbs news he heard trump use
the phrase burner phones in several
discussions and that trump did know
exactly what it meant
in a response trump said he never heard
the phrase burner phone i have no idea
what a burner phone is to the best of my
knowledge i've never even heard the term
bolton says he and trump spoke about how
people have used burner phones to avoid
having their calls scrutinized
um i mean you know
i know trump's not the brightest
but it did not pass the sniff test that
trump didn't know what a burner phone
was
and this is increasingly reeking of
watergate i would encourage everybody in
the audience who is disturbed by this
story as you should be and you want to
read a little bit more about it there's
a really good new piece in the new
republic by alex shepherd called trump's
missing phone records have a familiar
stink of criminality
and in that article
alex shepherd
discusses the analogies here to
watergate and
mentions that in terms of the amount of
missing phone data
it is more than 20 times longer in terms
of a gap in the records than what there
was in the watergate tapes i don't know
how many have recently reviewed
watergate and all of its different
elements but one of the things about
watergate was a gap in tapes which
ultimately scandalized richard nixon and
led to his resignation in 1974 uh and
the gap in the record with these trump
phone calls is more than 20 times bigger
than the gap in that uh um in the
watergate tapes the difference of course
is that at the time richard nixon was
president and so the entire scandal
precipitated his resignation trump is no
longer president and of course you and i
would like to think if people are
reasonable republicans would say okay
even if i liked his tax plan this is
just too much i can't vote for the guy
in 2024. unfortunately
that's not the case and not only are
there tens of millions of voters at
least still willing to vote for donald
trump still eager to vote for donald
trump in 2024
they become more emboldened by these
stories if you go and you look at
right-wing youtube right-wing twitter
right-wing tick-tock shows like real
america's voice and news max and all
these different places you see that they
are actually emboldened by these stories
saying these are part of the witch hunt
attacks meant to take down trump
unfairly
we renew our support for him
as a result of this investigation which
is really scary stuff we'll have all
these articles and more on our instagram
you can follow us there at david pakman
show we'll take a break we will talk
about that rick scott 11 point wacky
plan
after this short break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow so i don't know how many
of you remember it was uh a really big
day in my life but it may not have been
in your life uh about a month ago i i
did a breakdown of rick scott's 11-point
plan to save america and this was it was
notable because
it sort of seemed like in a sea of
cultural issues and
talking points that make no sense
a republican was actually putting
together a policy proposal and this is
the republican florida senator rick
scott so we looked at it the proposal
was absolutely absurd incredibly if if
rick scott got his way
the policies he proposes would be
incredibly damaging to the country a lot
of them weren't even really policies
they were just again cultural issues
masked as policy but we reviewed it
because it was actually something
apparently substantive from republicans
and it was a crazy and disastrous
proposal
rick scott went on fox news
and on fox news reporter john roberts
calls out rick scott for some of the
things in his plan and it's not you know
that john roberts is the be all end all
of journalism or whatever but here
he did a good job of saying here's stuff
that's in your proposal rick scott tries
to call them democratic talking points
and john roberts is like no no no
it's straight out of your proposal and
it is and rick scott doesn't know what
way you know what is up what is down it
doesn't make any sense
this is how
flaccid these proposals are where as
soon as they are questioned about them
they say well those are just democratic
spin
no it's in your proposal check this out
because putin's such a thug a murderous
thug
all right uh let's switch to politics
now because there's a lot that we've got
to look forward to between now and
november the 8th you recently put out an
11-point plan to rescue america right
two of the big points of which are quote
all americans should pay some income tax
to have skin in the game even if a small
amount currently over half of americans
pay no income tax it also says all
federal legislation sunsets in five
years if a law is worth keeping congress
can pass it again
so that would raise taxes on half of
americans and potentially sunset
programs like medicare medicaid and
social security
why would you propose something like
that in an election year
sure when john that's of course the
democrat talking points it's a little
bit no it's in the plan
it's in the plan but here's but here's
the thing about reality for a second
let's talk about that
so it's not a democratic talking point
it's in the plan
and also in the plan okay so now notice
how he first said it's it's a lie
and then when he can't say anything
other than well yeah it is in the plan
he says well there's also other things
in the plan now what john roberts is
saying is is true
um when rick scott says everyone should
pay at least some federal income tax you
have to remember there are lots of
people that end up paying no federal
income tax because
between a low income
and the standard deduction
and child tax credits and whatever you
end up paying zero federal income tax
now
you have to remember these folks pay a
lot of other taxes they pay sales taxes
they pay
excise taxes if they have a vehicle they
have car registration fees they may pay
state taxes it's not that they don't pay
taxes this is a popular right-wing
talking point
to say the rich are paying so much
and half the country pays no taxes well
okay you you're entitled to child tax
credits and the standard deduction etc
but it is part of their
talking point as to why the tax system
needs to be changed rick scott is then
confronted well that is going to
increase taxes
for half of americans per your own
favorite talking points and rick rick
scott says well that's that's democratic
propaganda no it's actually in your plan
then he switches to well here's other
stuff that's also in my plan says we
ought to every year talk about exactly
how we're going to fix medicare and
social security here's what's happening
no one that i know of wants to sunset
medicare social security but what we're
doing is we don't even talk about it
medicare goes bankrupt in four years
social security goes bankrupt in 12
years i think we are remember that
they've been using these bankruptcy
talking points for a long time and
they're all completely untrue to figure
out how we preserve those programs every
program that we care about we ought to
stay stop and take the time to preserve
those programs now understand what he's
saying here
he claims i don't want to get rid of
social security and medicare no i don't
want to do that but i do want us to
debate whether to keep them on a regular
basis so let's re phrase what he's
saying
he's saying
i want it to be on the table that we
might gut or eliminate social security
and or medicare
that he he wants that possibility at
least
i i mean i just fought the postal bill
because it put more responsibility on
medicare and took it off the postal
service and put medicare in a worse
position
now let's go back let's talk about taxes
for a second i'll put my record up
against anybody on tax cuts i tax i cut
taxes and fees a hundred times as
governor but now understand that that's
such a meaning i i don't even want to
waste time on this but this is how
politicians lie where he goes well
listen when i was governor i cut taxes
and fees 100 times you guys understand
that that can mean okay
he's cutting the vehicle
registration fee from 50 to 45 that's
one cut
he is changing the uh excise tax rate
from 1.05 percent to 1.03 that's a
second cut
these are sort of meaningless statements
and politicians are so good at just
off-handedly mentioning them here's
what's unfair we have people that don't
that could go to work and have figured
out how to have government pay their way
that's not right so that's actually what
this is about that's actually what this
it's about it's about cutting welfare
and all sorts of different programs so
understand that
the republican
there's some people who say oh
republicans want to
kill americans by putting people in
genocide camps or whatever and then some
republicans say it's democrats who want
to put people in genocidal concentration
camps or whatever no no no the way it
works is
republicans want to slowly chip away at
programs that enable people
to live in a dignified way
and take away the ability of folks to
afford
unexpected costly events or just the
cost of being alive and
this is the way they do it listen we we
should look at
whether medicare really makes sense to
keep we should justify whether social
security should keep going we should
look at food stamps we should make sure
that everybody's paying some federal tax
which means the poor make the poor pay
more in taxes that's how you do it it's
not you know these these 1984-esque
uh fema camps or whatever else it's it's
these little little cuts to take away
people's dignity and um
certainly
i don't know how much the fox audience
realizes the dishonesty and the absurd
nature of what rick scott is proposing
and his complete inability to defend it
here
but the best way to dismantle all of
these so-called plans is you go line by
line
and
explain to them
this is what it would do
how do you justify it half the time
they'll say that's not really what's in
my plan and then you go no it is here it
is and then the other half they'll just
explain it away with very
transparently bogus talking points we've
spoken before on the program about lara
logan lara logan is a
she at least was a journalist and she
did some really good work when she was
with 60 minutes
something happened to lara logan and i
know that many say david what happened
is she was brutally assaulted
when uh
doing coverage in the middle east
and she has ptsd that's what hap
maybe it is i i don't know
something happened to lara logan
where she is now on fox nation
repeating some of the most rancid
conspiracy theories that we have seen in
the political media space for the last
10 years and most recently lara logan
suggested
that darwinian evolution
may be a hoax funded by jews now she for
a while now has been using some of these
anti-semitic tropes and talking points
of
a globalist you almost when you hear the
word globalist you almost have to say
globalished like alex jones globalist
stuff
rothschilds all these different things
she appeared on
honestly i don't even know what this is
it's a show called and we know
and she suggested
that darwinian evolution may be a jewish
funded hoax
listen to this so now you've gone from
being a farmer who may not be able to
farm efficiently who may not be able to
feed as many people but guess what
he could feed he could grow food year
after year after year because who
created
seeds that are renewable like truly like
who created life
that is truly renewable what is the only
thing on earth that is actually
renewable
it's life
and they can you know go back to the big
bang theory and darwin i mean when i
found out does anyone know when who
employed darwin where darwin isn't comes
from
uh go ahead
well i mean you know look it up
the rothschilds yeah
it goes right back to 10 downing streets
the same people who employed darwin and
that's when darwin you know wrote his
theory of evolution and so on and so on
guys did did you know that
you know dart what what she's suggesting
here is
the theory of darwinian evolution didn't
come from darwin doing real science
jews the rothschilds hired darwin
and then all of a sudden he writes this
theory of evolution and then
what i'm not saying that none of that is
true i'm just saying dharma was hired by
someone to come up with a theory right
based on evidence okay fine but you know
even the people
fine i guess it was based on evidence
well the scientists all of the people
that can take you back to the big bang
what is the one question they can never
ever ever answer
they can never tell you whatever that
was whether it's the molecules or the
energy or you know all that stuff all
these scientists like that you know that
evil uh horrible person who's the
science advisor to klaus schwab at the
world economic forum who says there's no
such thing as freedom every there's no
such you know there's randomness but
that's not freedom and blah blah blah
there's probability and there's this and
there's that they can explain it away
any way you like but how did those
things come into being
you know and it was it was a combination
of
it's that question of what came first
the chicken or the egg right you can't
answer that scientifically now as many
of you already know
this is an often this is a sort of god
of the gaps
hypothesis or talking point which is any
phenomena that cannot yet be answered by
science or maybe never will but it
doesn't make a difference
you put god into those gaps so
we we don't know now
what was there before
everything i mean it's a very
complicated question it's a scientific
question it's a philosophical question
it's it's a big question
that doesn't mean
you know it's jesus or zeus or whatever
there's there's no evidence for that
when it comes to lara logan first of all
this is this is disgusting right i mean
jews funded the hoax of darwinian
evolution even if it was maybe based in
some fact that's her idea um do you
think that she started believing this
stuff so then fox hired her or is it
that fox hired her
and it got her to start spouting this
stuff it it's hard to say which way it
goes and there may be some some way in
which it's both
but this is a real-life cautionary tale
about a lot of different things about
how right-wing media will rot your brain
and listen if ptsd is part of what's
going on with lara logan
it's a cautionary tale about that as
well
and it's not for any of us to diagnose
what's going on but i feel it relevant
to mention that she did suffer
an insane situation
and
not long after that these have started
to be her ideas so make of it what you
will
uh no comment from fox about these
completely outrageous comments by lara
logan
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's take a few minutes to
look at this uh the rest of this very
dangerous interview that donald trump
gave to real america's voice you might
recall that about a half hour ago or 40
minutes ago at the start of the show or
earlier in the show we looked at another
request from donald trump to vladimir
putin putin's invading ukraine and trump
says to putin hey can you get me some
dirt on hunter biden that happened
yesterday it's not 2017 or whenever it
was 2016 2015 trump saying hey russia if
you're listening this interview in total
was absolutely sick and disgusting
very clearly donald trump extremely
sensitive about the small size of his
crowd on saturday at his rally listen to
this stands it
uh they
lie they cheat it's i've never seen
anything like it i never knew it was
that corrupt i knew it was
there was a lot of fake stuff going on
but since i got into politics i had a
lot of media before you know with the
apprentice and all the things i've done
and the business
but i've never seen anything like it
it's you cannot they will not write a
good story
uh i have great poll numbers they don't
put them out i have great things
happening like super confident alpha
male huh guys uh just the other day we
had a fantastic rally in georgia
some guy from i think it's npr or
something i never heard of the person
said oh the rally wasn't well attended
the sheriff just said it was 25 000
people he said it was
a couple of thousand people or less than
5 000 people
we had less than 5 000 people and we had
5 000 people in the first few rows i
think you were there your people your
cameramen are just saying yeah sir that
rally was packed they said sir the rally
was just absolutely packed so it was a
very it was it was the smallest crowd
for a trump rally i think in six years
and trump very very sensitive about it
trump continuing to play up the story of
inflation and supply chain issues but
playing it up with just weird talking
points that don't make any sense and of
course it's very clear that trump
doesn't have any idea how the real world
works take a listen to this an example
supply chain
you go to a store they don't have bread
we're like a third world country they
don't have things you go to buy
something at tiffany you're going to buy
something at a hardware store high low
i love that it's like listen
i don't know that you've ever been to a
grocery store to buy bread and i don't
know that you've ever been to a hardware
store looking for a drywall anchor but
in the middle he says if you go to
tiffany which is not exactly you know
relatable to most people they don't have
product
they say even me when i order things
like for furnishings for a building or
something trump's regularly ordering
tchotchkes off of amazon
they said it's going to take nine months
to get it used to be like same-day
service
um supply chain
we never even heard the term now of
course we did many of us you know in the
business field we
back even in business school we would do
case studies on supply chain but trump
says we never heard it before this is
maybe my favorite part of the interview
dave weigel is a reporter who's a friend
of the show he's a really good guy i've
known dave weigle for a really long time
here trump
doesn't like
what dave weigel had to say
check this out allies you can't even get
into him the people get their six and i
have to put up with this
i had the washington post uh write a
story that a rally i was giving in an
arena
that the arena was empty
it was a man that you know very well in
the washington post
and it was empty about 10 hours before
and he will eventually name dave so just
keep listening sitting there and he
showed an empty thousands of people
outside waiting to get in
and then they came and he had to do an
apology actually because the arena was
packed and you know who went after the
people in the arena
because they saw that it was an empty
arena and you couldn't
i mean they used the the steps as seats
it was thousands and thousands of people
right more than far more than an nba
game
his name was weigel or wigal for the
washington post and he had to do an
apology
i can assure you that dave weigel is
absolutely loving this trump also says
democrats are quote bad on religion
but it's like florida everyone said oh
florida florida
but i won in like a landslide
the way you win is you have to win them
because
when they have
no voter id defund the police sanctuary
cities weak military whether raise your
taxes no energy independence all things
that were
all done
and they're against it now what is
really interesting about this
is every single one of those claims we
could actually go through them you know
one at a time trump actually says if we
look at the subtitles here
we have no voter id well actually
there's plenty of places that have voter
id the issue is the implementation of
voter id defund the police no serious
democrats are actually looking to defund
the police sanctuary cities these are
municipal decisions that are made and it
doesn't have anything to do with the
federal government as donald trump uh
claims that it does
weak military
democrats keep rubber stamping military
budgets just like do republicans raise
your taxes well not on people earning
under 400 000 and then of course no
energy independence we produced as much
oil as we used in 2020 and also in 2021
under joe biden i mean all of these
things are not true but his followers
don't care that we're
all done
and they're against it
bad on religion
bad on the second amendment
bet on oil think of it they said i'm
gonna have a close race in texas
but they're against god
right you just look at it
god guns and oil
i won texas and i'm in a record right no
there was no record actually the trump
won texas
by quite a small margin for a republican
and it's this is the difficulty when we
say we just got to talk to these people
david just talk to these people and
they'll see reason
there are so many lies upon lies i mean
it's a throwaway in here right it's it's
a throwaway that i won texas by a record
no you didn't and it's not even the
point of the actual story and so it
becomes almost a physical impossibility
to unwind the lie upon lie upon lie a
one last clip here and this is an
interesting policy thing it started to
be floated by matt gates the radical
republican congressman under
investigation for child sex trafficking
trump's former propagandist steve bannon
has talked about this what if
republicans win the house in 2022 in a
few months
and then they make donald trump the
speaker of the house because remember
you don't have to
be a member of congress to be speaker of
the house trump actually says here he's
not interested in it oh i want to ask a
fellow while we're talking about
congress because these comments went
viral
at the rally when congressman matt gates
brought up you
being nominated for speaker of the house
and i
your reaction intrigued me because i
couldn't tell one way or the other how
you felt about that your reaction
no i think that it's not something i
wanted a lot of people bring it up it's
brought up all the time yeah
no it's not something i want to do i
want to
look at what's happening and then we're
going to be doing something else no it's
not something we're going to be doing
something else
you guys know why trump really doesn't
want to be so okay his ego would not
allow him to go from having been
president to being speaker of the house
fine i could totally get that that makes
sense from an ego standpoint
being speaker of the house
actually is more work
the way trump would have to be doing it
and compared to the way trump did the
job of the president because as
president in theory you would imagine
being president is a very very busy job
trump had hours of tv time in the
morning and then he would often spend
the afternoon tweeting before he was
banned from twitter and so on and so
forth so it would be a lot more work for
trump to be the speaker of the house but
interesting that he's saying i just
don't want to do it and that basically
puts an end to that discussion i mean if
trump doesn't want to do it he doesn't
want to do it so there's trump very
strange interview uh uh his mood seems
sort of altered and granting just any
old interview these days
um and and i think that we will soon see
a greater level of involvement in the
2022 midterms and it's really important
that the left have a strategy in place
because otherwise they act as as
cartoonishly ignorant as they are
they're going to run away with it unless
the left gets it together
ted cruz appeared on the laura ingraham
show on fox news last night and this is
if you were to look up projection in the
dictionary it should have an interactive
video clip of ted cruz's appearance on
fox news last night so let me set this
up for you
one of the
phenomena that we've
noticed with republicans over the last
five or six years
is whenever they really start harping on
democrats are doing x or democrats will
do x
we need to very seriously look at
whether what they mean is we are doing
this or we plan to do this and i'll give
you some examples donald trump and i
know many of you have heard this donald
trump said so many times we can't vote
for hillary in 2016 because she can't be
trusted with her email she's using
personal email she can't uh be trusted
with classified and secret information
and on and on
and it really didn't make sense and it
was actually trump who planned to do all
of those very things trump completely
untrustworthy with secret information
from allies spilling secrets from allies
to a russian spy recruiter in the oval
office many in trump's inner circle
including mark meadows ivanka trump
jared kushner
using private email while they were
working for donald trump trump eating
notes that are supposed to be preserved
as records trump power flushing 10 to 15
times notes that are supposed to be kept
for presidential records so when he
starts talking when they start talking
about the left is gonna do this thing we
should be like are they actually doing
it and often the answer is yes for six
months trump saying they're going to do
fraud in the 2020 election we can't do
vote by mail they're going to win and
they're going to steal it and all this
different stuff and of course it was
trump and his acolytes who filed 60
frivolous legal complaints insisted that
vans and machines and all these
different things mean that they actually
had the election stolen from them they
were the ones trying to steal the
election so now with that context in
mind
listen to what with a straight face
ted cruz says last night on fox news
he has no shame listen listen very
closely you cannot accept it as a result
they know they're going to lose
and nancy pelosi is not going to go
quietly she's going to scream she's
already preparing to scream the election
was stolen and by the way what she means
by stolen is people showed up to vote
against democrats that's what stealing
the election is and remember democrats
don't believe in democracy
this how can he say this with a straight
face this is exactly what they did in
2020
when they said in 2020 it was stolen
what it was was that more democrats came
out to vote that's that's what happened
when they say nancy pelosi is planning
to claim it was stolen no that's what
you guys did and that's exactly what
they're going to do again depending on
the results in november here's a bonus
uh ted cruz clip here
uh where he complains
he hasn't spoken with joe biden
personally and that that's like a
problem in some way you know the
question you just asked eric i actually
get to ask that almost every day
somebody says who's really running
things and let me tell you the scary
thing
i have no idea
so biden's been president what 15 months
in that entire time i have not spoken
with him once
and that's true of almost every
republican senator i got to say that's
weird
why does biden have to speak to them to
show he's really the president why would
biden speak to ted cruz ted cruz is out
of his mind and this is a really new
common thing on the right kyle
rittenhouse has also been pulling this
clearly joe biden is doing something
wrong because he hasn't met with kyle
rittenhouse i was like why would biden
meet with kyle rittenhouse or you know
is is calling you out on twitter uh what
would you like them to know most about
your story right
um yeah i was attacked i was 17 years
old i was attacked and had to defend
myself and
not a racist not a white supremacist i'm
not a domestic terrorist i'm not a
murderer and anybody who wants to sit
down and have a conversation i'm more
than open i reached out to joe biden
several times crickets nothing he still
hasn't replied so it just shows how much
of a man he is to not sit down
talk to a 19 year old
why does joe biden have to talk to kyle
rittenhouse why does joe biden have to
talk to ted cruz these people are so
self-centered thinking everything is
about them it is truly unbelievable but
ted cruz
apparently with
absolutely no sense of irony or shame
showing up and saying guys if we're not
careful democrats might try to claim
they won even though they didn't yeah
well they'd be taking a lesson from you
wouldn't they ted we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
voicemail's pouring in about the will
smith slap of chris rock at the oscars
on sunday people wanting to talk about
race people wanting to talk about
domestic violence people wanting to talk
about defending one's honor here is
someone who's just baffled by some of
the response we've seen to the incident
take a listen to this
hi david i'm like truly baffled by the
responses i'm seeing to
the will smith slap
i'm watching a video by jocko willick
right now
who i actually think is the perfect
example for everything that is wrong in
america right now
i guess he wants every man woman and
child in america to be in a navy heel
platoon
and to live their lives like they were
overseas and tasked with killing an
innocent
civilian family or something like that
so
that's for good to him there's just a
way of letting off steam
you talk smack you get smacked so
we're all about smacking people nowadays
it really is weird now i think it's
important for context to show that
we now have i mean listen we can
we can get polling very quickly on any
topic in the united states most people
are taking the side of chris rock in the
sense that they're saying listen he told
a joke and there's no justification for
the physical violence but even some
people on twitter have tweeted to me and
they've said listen jada pinkett smith
has taken a lot of crap over the years
well why
are you justifying violence because
that's really what it's about and at the
end of the day
uh these are millionaires sitting in the
front row at the oscars where you know
there's some degree of like a kind of
roast scenario there um and alopecia is
not what we would call
a disability it is a medical condition
and it's not even really clear what
chris rock knows about it and you can
talk whatever you want but we're we're
talking about words here and then we're
talking about an adult walking on stage
and slapping chris rock and it is weird
it is baffling to some degree
how quickly some are jumping to defend
acts of physical violence it's it's
disturbing we've got a great bonus show
for you today russia is claiming that
they're scaling down military action in
kiev but i think we're right to be
skeptical of it we'll talk about what we
know joe biden has also made lynching a
hate crime in the united states and some
house republicans are angry that madison
hawthorne is telling stories about
coke-laden orgies in washington d.c we
will talk about all of those stories
on the bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com
to get instant access